if I know I'm going to post it back if I
know if I'm going to do edit 2 or edit 3
I usually do delete it how quickly it
depends on the platform I know on
Instagram within 20 minutes what's the
fastest you'll take down in one hour on
Tick Tock 10 minutes on Instagram 10
minutes on Instagram you know that you
want to do something about cam reddish
is hot a little bit for the next he's
into coffee
camera Edition coffee
sit on the gram and in 10 minutes
because of the math you know that it
didn't hit but you know you're going to
give it another AT-AT you will take it
down yes we have it figured out
algorithms obviously change but for the
most part they don't change like every
other day so so we know that like within
two minutes this video should have 500
likes within five minutes it should have
a thousand like we already know all the
built-in stuff oh a lot of people feel
the takedown is not good like I haven't
seen that and it seems like you haven't
seen that either like taking it down and
coming back a couple hours later with
something different while you work on
re-editing that you have not seen a
negative effect I've never seen it I've
done it since 2018 for a lot of people